eu conheci Paris cara merda as
pessoas tudo educada lá os cachorros são
educados em Paris cachorro Chega para
mijar no poste chega outro pozinho fala
pardão posso mijar primeiro ó II pode
mijar o cachorrinho vem e mija e ainda
sai assim ó depois ó assim ó é lindo
cara Londres tudo é bonito em londr o
cemitério é bonito em Londres o
cemitério é lindo cara eu tava vendo
aquelas coras bonitas passando assim eu
achando lindo aquelas coisas falei o
cemitério Vou entrar vou ver como é eu
entrei Tava tendo um enterro que eu eu
quas bato palma para esse enterro de
tentão não fora do normal tava tocando a
musiquinha assim ó a musiquinha fazia
assim
ó saudado
[Música]
assim coisa mais linda que eu já vi na
minha vida a mulher com véu as crianças
chorando baixo eu nunca tinha visto os
meninos só assim
ó falei que coisa linda cara